a square circumscribes a circle all
right so you got to stop straightaway
okay now the reason why I'm giving you
these kinds of problems is for the exact
purpose that you practice the kind of
problem-solving strategies that will be
useful to you when you're doing that
working mathematically section at the
very end of the test will you get these
exact questions I have no idea probably
not but all the strategies that we've
worked through here well I can guarantee
will be useful in approaching the
questions you will do ok so there's
enough similarities I think that will be
useful to you that's the idea now as
usual I draw the diagram that they've
given us that's nice ok let me introduce
this read language a square
circumscribes now all it means is it
goes round ok and you can see on the
diagram what that means the square all
of its edges they press onto the surface
there extra space it's not like I have
something like this for instance there's
a circle inside a square right but the
square isn't pretty on all sides so it's
not the same kind of relationship now
let's keep going through the question
it's a radius of 40 centimeters so if
you put in your Center there okay from
the center to the circumference that's
40 centimeters now that's just the plan
yeah radius okay now it's not diameter
should be careful you got to watch out
for your language there a point is
chosen at random within the square okay
so somewhere in where I've drawn they
pick a point like they're all there well
they're wherever we don't know where
find the probability okay we've done a
few of these questions on maybe what
should I write now as soon as I hear or
see the word probability what can I say
what is probability yeah
it isn't is something over something I
heard that right
ah good sample space is it but it's
actually the denominator your dubiety
so that's that's all the possible
outcomes what's my one on the top not
the possible ones what is it a favorable
favorable as in that's the ones that
we're interested in favorable outcomes
what we want over what's possible okay
find the probability that the chosen
point is not within the circle and then
it talks out the answer later on and the
format they wonder okay so let's stop
it's how long yeah
where are the favorable outcomes we can
actually put this on our diagram right
they want you to be within the circle or
not within the circle they went outside
don't they so I can shake this in just
to give myself a bit of a um a visual
cue okay so I'm going to shade that part
looks like this yeah good okay so by
doing this you can sort of give yourself
a better idea of what you need to
calculate okay so in order to work out
that shaded area let me let me actually
write out some steps myself okay number
what I'm gonna have to work out the area
of the square yes number two I'm gonna
have to work out the area of this circle
that's inside okay number three I'm
gonna have to work out the difference
that's the shaded part yeah and then
lastly I'm gonna use that to work out
the probability okay so let's do this
one by one go through the steps what's
the area of square what do you need to
work out a squares area what kind of
information you do I need a side don't I
and I only need one side cuz once I've
got one I've got all of them don't know
so now what is the answer what is this
it's 80 but how can you tell that is 80
where does that number come from
yeah yeah you're gonna
good perfect so that's the great thing
about the radius right that since it's
the distance from the center to the
circumference it's always the distance
in the simplicity so that must be 40 as
well
therefore 80 is correct okay so
therefore the area of the square you
don't need much working out for this to
you you can actually get your calculator
out and you can work it out straight
away what do I do this 80 to get the
area that's where what kind of shape is
this again fun to square so you take
this and you square it don't you
it's a squared yeah I did tricky sorry
that's all that's not succeeding on you
it's on what's 8 times 8 8 squares 64
and there's going to be now this is a
zero there stop got it
yeah all right what have we established
so far yeah go down we've got an area
okay good now's the area to square we
need more than that though we need the
area of the circle don't wait how I do
that circumference will tell me a
distance but I want an area like a shade
of thing now
circumference is 2 PI R that's to the
form of area is very very similar as
different yeah so that too is just if
you like it's almost it's just moved
okay now do you remember how we remember
which one scenario yeah it's like
centimeter squared or meters squid or
something like that
there's always a square okay so time I'm
baack which ones which
now what do we need to work out the area
then we just need the radius though we
but that's the first piece of
information we got so what's the area of
the circle
it'll be color pi times the radius 4t
squared
okay what's 4t squared xx times 44 times
4 is 16
pretty should be 1,600 you can check it
out on your calculator I've got the four
in the fall they become 16 oh and then
I've got the zeros they become cool
thank you
I feel very validated that's great again
now I want this sum the difference
because that's what the shaded part is
isn't it
that's the shaded part so it's the
square take away the circle I've
hollowed it out if you like okay so
therefore it's gonna be this minus this
the square minus the circle that's going
to be the shaded part that's glad is
that okay
square minus the circle yep all right
now I've got on a piece I need to work
out this part the favorable outcomes
that's the part that I want right and we
said that's the shaded area that's the
one I just worked out 6,400 minus
sixteen hundred hi
now I know you could get your calculator
I'll work out what this is okay but
that's gonna be enough to approximate
and I like to approximate by the very
end what accurate that way okay that's
the favorable outcomes what's the sample
space it's the everything that could
possibly happen so come back to the
question it says a point is chosen at
random where opponent but but where are
they chosen what's the visible where
that's right so somewhere in here so
therefore I need to put in the area of
the square right this is the total
number of places I could possibly be
okay or the area that corresponds to it
so that's it that's that's the fraction
but they do want us to approximate so
you leave your calculate of it okay now
oh did I leave my
oh yeah that's right okay good now
before I punch this into my calculator
I'm just gonna simplify this a little
bit and factorizing which we learn under
algebra that's gonna help us here okay
so have a look at them rewrite it for me
can we factorize this yeah what can we
take out we can take out zeros to start
with let me let me do that so I'll get
64 and I'll get 16 pi can we take out
anything else I will in a second but can
I can I factorize out anything here 64
and 16 can I take anything out now I'll
admit the numbers are pretty big but if
you check with your calculator I'm
pretty sure that 64 divided by 16 is 4
all right go check out so with these
numbers I can take out another factor of
16 I'll get this 1600 now at the front
four of these one of these okay so the
reason why this is good is because now I
can make these numbers all really small
I can cancel on that 1600 and I'll just
be left with 4 down the bottom much
nicer smaller numbers
and on 4 minus PI calling 4 okay now by
the way quick question what are the
units on this thing what are the units
yes hmm good question good question
I started with sending me this denied
everything was in centimeters these are
areas so I guess kneeling in a square
centimeters ah but this is a probability
it's not a link it's not a measurement
it's not an area there are no units it's
just that that's it right if I said to
you you know what's the probability I'm
on tour today I don't have any coins on
me
what's the property up near a foot being
heads or tails you don't say like half a
centimeter or 30 you know meters
whatever you say fifty percent fifty
fifty oh so there you go that's that now
it's we'll put some eight how far they
want us to approximate this a what's the
approximation they [ __ ] we've got
approximation on another skills do you
remember what how to do this they want
two decimal places so get your
calculator out okay and let's punch this
in and we're gonna get some weirdo
decimals okay so let's do this okay
someone buy the answer check if you get
the same thing as maybe someone got it
anyone got it I'll give you a clue
starts with zero point anyone oh yes
okay I'm gonna stop there now the reason
why I can stop is okay
they only want two decimal places right
stuff that come on that's annoying say
so I just want the two of the one
they're not really good okay they go I'm
done that's the answer so let me just
repeat cuz there was a lot of stuff
there it is confusing okay you had to
start by getting a picture for yourself
okay you can't do anything after the
picture that if it's a geometry type
question okay
then they say it's a probability so then
I knew I had a fraction involved and
then had to work out what are the bits
that are going to go into the fraction
that's what this is about okay and then
you put it all together your number hops
out the end all right